welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home's new
trailer opened up the floodgates to the
multiverse ending the dry spell of
spider-man content with a sundell huge
of tv spots and promo clips with even
more footage and dialogue and weirdly
unfinished vfx for us to go through
frame by frame i can't stop him from
knowing the scene is actually set at
night time and this new background ain't
full on anyone i'm gonna break down all
this new footage and all the details
that you might have missed let's start
with the new footage of electro some
visitors from every universe you know to
take this away from me
whoa so first things first for whatever
reason these promos lower the pitch on
jamie foxx's voice you're not gonna take
this away from me you're not gonna take
this away from me it puts the lotion in
the basket and now we know what exactly
electro doesn't want peter parker to
take away from him confirming what i
originally spotted in my trailer
breakdown last week that electro is
using an iron man chest arc reactor
specifically this is the older
generation new element arc reactor mark
1 or mark ii with a triangular inlay
that tony stark constructed using the
new element he rediscovered in iron man
2. this is a version of the reactor that
he went on to use in iron man 3 before
surgically removing all the shrapnel and
chucking this model into the ocean
probably irradiating countless sea
creatures now the next model of the arc
reactor after that was attached to
tony's suits rather than his flesh and
was thinner only need to go as deep as a
chest plate not like a double stacked
hockey puck that need to go inside of
its chest and to be clear the reactor
that electro is using is not the proof
tony stark has a heart one that was
attached to tony's funeral wreath and
end game that was an earlier model from
the first iron man so it looks like no
one's grave robbing or at least that we
know about but someone might have gone
scuba diving off the coast of malibu or
black market traders could have been
scavenging spare iron man tech from the
avengers compound as seems to be the
case in hawkeye now compared to his
appearance in the 2014 film electro also
now uses as conduits armored plates
strapped onto him in a harness those
look a lot like the apparatus ivan vanko
whiplash used in iron man 2 to channel
electrical energy which is also powered
by arc reactors that venko built from
his father anton's blueprints so two
pieces of tech that both appeared in the
same movie both of which might have been
kept in storage on the avengers compound
so however max stillen got his hands on
this arc reactor this plus stark's
nanotech and the vanco gear could have
all come from the same source and if
that source is revealed in hawkeye folks
all eyes on wilson fist kingpin calling
it now never been wrong before right but
let's move on to the new footage of
peter and doctor strange first there's
footage of them in strange's confinement
location multiverse is real i'll fix
this but i'm gonna need some help
let's catch some multiverse men yeah
peter's calling back his line from far
from home i'm sorry you're saying
there's a multiverse because i thought
that was just theoretical so now being
told that there is actually a multiverse
peter might feel a bit more vindicated
after being fooled by mysterio's lie or
wonder if he's still trapped in the
illusion also notice here that peter's
necktie is severed so that might have
been cut off when doc attacked his chest
as those nanobots were rushing in to
cover the hole then peter and strange on
the train
there has to be another wing there whoa
so before strange's trains seem to
charge through the grand canyon or a
location like that and then split into
this cool rotating cyclone of like a
half dozen train cars but now rising up
through the rocky terrain are the
skyscrapers of manhattan with a second
canyon cityscape mirrored from above so
it's almost like peter could be using
the bendiness of the universe right now
and portals and whatnot to try to escape
to a remote location away from doctor
strange but then strange is dragging
them back into the city folded reality
like a book on a spider what a way to
ruin a book and a spider but then an
extended version of strange tricking
peter into webbing his own foot
this is why i never had kids
[Music]
that might be one of the coolest things
that's ever happened to me but don't
ever do that again hmm doctor strange
talking about never having kids you know
who else never actually had kids that
baby crazy witch i suspect is
controlling this wizard never been wrong
before right now if you're watching this
video obviously you spend quite a bit of
your time on the internet and i'm sure
that applies to everything like shopping
think about it online shopping is
basically the only shopping that happens
these days and that's where today's
sponsor honey comes in honey is the
number one shopping tool in america it's
the free tool that scours the internet
for coupon codes and automatically tests
them at checkout get honey on your
computer for free in two easy clicks and
then when you're checking out on your
favorite sites honey pops up and all you
have to do is click apply coupons you
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons for that site if honey finds a
working code you will watch the prices
drop and big news now you can get cash
back with honey now as you shop honey
will drop down and let you know if it
offers cash back on that site click
activate cash back and you will get cash
in your paypal account get cash back on
the stuff you're going to buy anyways
delivery pizza tastes even better when
you get some extra money for that
pepperoni i'm sorry 17 million people
are saving money with honey take it from
me if you have a computer honey should
be on it get honey for free by going to
joinhoney.com new rockstars that's
joinhoney.com new rockstars so they know
that i sent you thanks honey for
sponsoring today's video now much of the
new footage shows doc ox battle with
peter on this bridge i underestimated
you peter do i know you
looks like we got competition
you think your fancy new suit's gonna
save you
[Music]
you're not peter parker i am so confused
right now ah so we see how doc ock
mistakes tom holland peter parker
initially for his toby maguire peter
parker just by assuming he's peter got a
fancy new suit now doc tells his claws
that they're in competition with peter's
mechanical iron spider arms but notice
how his claws have the red light
illuminated which in the 2004 spider-man
2 film that was that movie's way of
showing whether the claws were in
control of the neural link in doc's
spinal cord or if he was controlling
them so white light meant that otto was
in charge red light meant that the arms
were in charge so this means that the
arms are currently in control in this
moment also the license plate that i
pointed out in the breakdown which was
asm8183 which i speculated could be a
nod either to a comic's issue where
kingpin appears or one where ant-may is
hospitalized and peter almost gets mowed
over by the big wheel that plate has now
been replaced with this one rnk810
which means nothing they covered it up
now for far from home john watts did
include a hydroman reference in the
trailer for that movie that was then
removed in the theatrical cut but they
didn't remove that from subsequent
trailers for that movie which makes me
now think that we might be onto
something with that old license plate
but let's move on to a new clip of happy
hogan calling peter
this is peter leave a message yeah peter
this is happy
who are those guys huh
one of the guys made a mud what's going
on call me back i love it that finally
after peter leaving happy dozens of
unanswered texts and voicemails it's now
happy having to leave peter a desperate
voicemail and this gives us a bit more
relief that happy might make it away
from that feast headquarters battle
safely as well as aunt may because now
happy seems to be unpacking seeing
sandman and probably electro and goblin
thinking sandman was made of mud but
does not appear to be in any particular
anguish like over a loved one or himself
charred in wildfire there are a few new
shots of sandman in their universe they
all die fighting spider-man we see him
swirling around the statue of liberty
here and then reaching out to grab
spider-man but also a new shot of the
lizard
was that a dinosaur yeah and you'll
notice the lizard has four fingers
meaning this film is following that
moment in the 2012 amazing spider-man
when captain stacy shot his hand that
had five lizard fingers on it and then
it regenerated with four digits and then
lastly a few alternate takes of mj and
peter just run it by us next time you
break the universe deal you're thinking
i'm about to do something that could
break the universe
oh i know you run it by us and then this
moment ever since i got bit by that
spider
i've only had one week where my life has
felt normal that was when you found out
ah this gives us our best look yet at
the new york post that mj is reading and
the headline reads peter parker and his
spider minions and at the bottom his
hypnotic spider senses seduced jones and
then something else well mj's name is
michelle jones so both she and peter are
embroiled in this page six goss but also
if that's the context of this story ned
might also be rumored to be part of this
love triangle i mean it's something you
know aunt may was at least curious about
when she walked in on them in homecoming
i just think it's pretty gross for a
newspaper to be talking about the
seduction tactics of 17 year olds like i
feel kind of gross talking about it
folks it's just sometimes when you zoom
in enhance on this stuff in the pursuit
of nerd movie trivia you don't like what
you find hey you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me at ea vos follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
and breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you